اللحظه عدد كبير طبعا من
الجرحى جراء الانفجار في تقسيم في اسطنبول
هذه الصور طبعا ربما انها لحظه وقوع هذا
الانفجار وفزع الناس في هذه المنطقه وفي
هذا الشارع اذا هذه صور متداوله نتابعها
واياكم للحظه الانفجار الاولى في منطقه
تقسيم
اسطنبول كما نشاهد هذه الصور المتداوله
همم
والتي علقت عليها وسائل الاعلام التركيه
ونقلت بانه همم بانه سمع دوي انفجار كبير
في هذه
المنطقه
وباكدت وقوع حتى الان 11 اصابه همم بعض
الانباء تتحدث كما ذكرنا عن وقوع ضحايا لا
تاكيدات حتى هذه اللحظه الشرطه التركيه
كانت قد اغلقت قبل قليل هذا الشارع شارع
تقسيم في اسطنبول ونعيد مره اخرى هذه صور
المتداوله للحظه الانفجار همم طبعا هذه
المنطقه منطقه تقسيم في اسطنبول هي منطقه
همم سياحيه منطقه تتواجد فيها العديد طبعا
من همم
المطاعم والمقاهي ايضا كذلك والمحلات
التجاريه هي منطقه تجاريه سياحيه كذلك
تواجد فيها الكثير من المشات الكثير من
المره ومن السياح ايضا فبالتالي هي منطقه
همم مهمه وربما ايضا منطقه سياحيه تستهدف
السواح داخل همم اسطنبول لكنها تتعرض في
هذه اللحظات الى انفجار وصفه الاعلام
التركي كما ذكرنا بانه انفجار همم قوي
انفجار ايضا همم كبير همم تبعنا واياكم
اللحظات الاولى لهذا الانفجار همم الفيديو
ايضا بين همم من خلال هذه همم الصور همم
ربما همم فزع الناس تراجع الناس عن هذه
المنطقه التي تعرضت كما ذكرنا لانفجار
كبير حتى